all right hot breath averse welcome back
to hot breath live comedians on skype
talking comedy this is the show where
you learn comedy from the pros if you're
watching this on YouTube just be aware
that all the questions are being asked
in our Facebook group so go into the
description request to join the group
and then you can start connecting with
guests like today's who today's guest
out of almost I mean over 200 interviews
with comedians he has been on the get
list from the beginning I was actually
going to fly to New York to interview
this gentleman before the pandemic so
now lucky for you you also get to be a
part of this by asking your own
questions in the Facebook group so
without further ado welcome to hot
breath the one and only
Jesse David Fox ladies and gentlemen
give it up for Jesse David Fox everyone
yes yes there's there's a sound effect
there's a clapping sound effect people
are hearing so no worries there so first
off thank you for doing this I'm a huge
fan you've definitely been an
inspiration for this show and just
what's possible within a podcast and
within the comedy world so I had a lot
of questions as an interview but then
also has a comedian so I want to take a
page out of your book and use a case
study of one of your interviews to kind
of interweave all my questions so
thought went into that don't worry this
was not the spontaneous as soon as I got
confirmation I was like alright
everything Jesse David Fox just a fog
everything just like when I book
centered to entertainer I had like 24
hour notice so for that entire time I
was just saturating my brain with Cedric
the Entertainer everything so for you a
lot of people may not know that good one
the idea was sparked when you
interviewed Jerry Seinfeld and he said
the most interesting thing he likes to
talk about is jokes and you were like oh
well there's a show so I thought
we could dive into that interview as
like a case study on the entire process
of starting out with even how were you
able to book Jerry Seinfeld for the
interview so I I've been working vulture
now for seven a half years and just as
time working folks over seven half years
and been doing the podcast for about
three years but all of my many jobs at
vulture one is booking vulture festival
which is a annual and so it was I
believe that might even been the second
year and second or third year and I you
know we're just like thinking people to
reach out to I was always a fan of Jerry
and we reached out coincidentally that
weekend was the weekend before the new
season of comedians and cars was coming
out mm-hmm so he had something to
promote so he it just timing worked and
they're like fine we'll do this thing I
think the reason he agreed first someone
else did an interview with him for
vulture who wasn't me buddy like that
anything fight enough and then for me to
do it I sent him clips of things I wrote
about comedy
Iida had not heard back if you read it
or if just his team reviewed it and like
oh this person knows what he's talking
about but that was sort of it which was
sort of like I knew what they that I
knew was doing I'm trying to think if I
had interviewed John Mulaney by that
point um like I did it's a big John
Mulaney interview but and that was sort
of it which was just sort of like you
want to do this thing I proved that I
knew enough about comedy and he didn't
really have any expectations because he
does stuff like this pride periodically
and he doesn't like it he just like well
I'll do it right because that's part of
the job but I don't think he had any
expectations if it like it necessarily
being like I think he would enjoy doing
yeah and with booking guests is
primarily because it is with him it was
the timing of comedians and cars there's
a promotional angle you can spin on it
when you're pitching guests but is it
mostly when you're booking a guest are
you going through a publicist is it some
of them are friends but as what you know
we want to start booking bigger guests
on this show Jessie how do we do it
even the people i know i booked through
the publicist because they're if they
have a publicist that means they want
opposed to be doing work and that means
they're you don't want to have to
maintain their own schedule and it's
just like way easier like a lot of
people say yes and then and be like and
then but not really know if they when
they can do it they pay a person to like
tell them when they should be doing
interviews so i'm always it's always
usually through publicist unless they
sort of see someone's gonna be in town
so I'm like hey you're gonna be tired of
it but sometimes it's through managers
but and you know we'll get pitched
movies or TV shows in general from being
the site and then I'll usually just
float the idea through those pictures
like oh they're pitching a movie and I'm
like oh this person is a movie or you
know Netflix has got I have a good
relation with Netflix as I've done a lot
of them so they'll be like these
questions we have coming up we'd be
interested in they've helped mmm do that
relationship and then but you know it's
like pegs are useful if it means people
are doing press that wouldn't normally
do press but I don't necessarily need to
do it I think sometimes specialists and
specials it's good to have a little
break so they're not just sort of in
junket mode and we're they're answering
the same things over and over again
also you can then sort of answer you can
ask them questions based on the same
state or to answer the million times so
it sort of it varies it used to be based
on if I'm gonna be in LA I reach out to
certain people and I'm gonna be if
people gonna be in New York obviously
now it's a lot different because
everything's done in my apartment and
did you say pegs like peg sorry like
news packs
is to use jargon uh-huh what a Nissen
like like a peg is something to have a
reason for why someone's doing crafts so
like the release of a TV show with
gotcha gotcha and when you're reaching
out to a publicist is it do you have a
press kit attached to the email do you
have like a template that you use I
could use a template but for some reason
I write the email out every time mm-hmm
we're just sort of explain show is
explaining who the guests had been and I
try to curate that based on either whose
most famous who I know the comedian
would think it's most famous who are
clients of the publicity firm and then
some like rough numbers I think also as
the show's gotten more popular and just
as its diamond what does it get more
popular more people know of it but also
as more publicists know of it because
I've worked with their firm I just sort
of like do they want to do good what did
they already know what it is because one
a thing is like you know these publicist
work together so when the thing is seen
as a good opportunity like people know
like oh our comedy clients we should try
to get them on the show
gotcha yeah okay cool so yeah moving on
I'm coming from the bottom up you're now
hop where people are like reaching up to
you so I'm trying to get it like what
does that climb but you opened up with
Jim Gaffigan so it's kind of like like
the show starts with Jim Gaffigan so
it's quite an an impressive roster from
the jump
yeah I mean I did Neil Neil and Jim
Gaffigan I recorded in the same day
first you interviews a different show it
was the same day and Jim I you know he
just was pitching he had a special
coming out and you know I had enough
reputation from just writing in general
right yeah this is new I and Neil I too
interviewed before but then the fact
that I had Neil and Jim was a lot that
like helped me get a certain people
Christian shawl I sort of knew from
interviewing her passing
so that like the first season was a lot
of people let I do like the first few
episodes were like I had some
relationship with or except for Weird Al
which was like a complete Shaun the dart
and he just said and like he was
promoting a small thing I couldn't
believe he said yes and then from then
it felt like had enough big enough names
that I was able to sort of have like
enough people that I can point to gotcha
and then I just kept on going and then
like more famous people more famous
people then it's like at this point like
I have like famous people on the show
that's like part of this yeah right
awesome
so let's get into the interview
preparation side of it as well because
that's something I value not only in
this show and doing research but then in
researching you about your research and
hearing that we share a lot of the same
practices where we may be listening to
an interview at double speed while
reading an article about that person
while maybe having their Twitter like
just constantly just absorbing and
really trying to learn from all of their
different interviews and kind of
distilling it into one so when it came
to interviewing Jerry Seinfeld like what
is what is that preparation like because
you had a whole list in the interview
that people can see on YouTube it's
amazing you have like papers on stage
like what is the interview prep for
Jerry Seinfeld I'm trying to remember
I forgot that there's the video of it so
you can see I mean I always like
long-form paper just cuz that's how my
brain visualizes a lot of people our
next cards but I don't memorize order as
much as I do spaced so Jerry I knew
there are certain things I wanted to hit
because it was supposed to be
wide-ranging but start with comedians
and cars and I knew you know like I was
not planning on people necessarily being
able to watch it and I just sort of like
I want to entertain the audience I want
to sort of like move along to different
topic and I knew I didn't want to talk
about certain things and then so I'm
trying to think how much work I did for
that I I mean I did less work than I do
now or at least especially at the peak
of the show but
I mean I watched all the comedian cars
I've read and you know I read every
interview I could find but I didn't like
and I skimmed his sort of book and I but
it didn't like really like let me read
every interview he did in the 80s and
try to find that or you know which is
something I probably would would have
done at the time the show where I was
sort of at a peak there was this one
thing I listened to which was he did
this one interview you can buy as a CD
micro Biglia told me about it it's
called it's called like on come on
comedy yeah I've heard that yeah yeah so
it's really interesting and so I
listened to that you know because I
didn't need to get so deep I was just
trying to get a sense and try to get a
sense of the type of things he liked to
talk about you know because when you're
doing public interviews like in front of
people where people have we're trying to
the conversation should flow more you
can't edit it it should be fun for the
audience in a different way you should
be sending people up to sort of be able
to like talk for a few minutes on end
and be more performative you know you
are not trying to surprise them or talk
to things then might be sort of
complicated to get into you're trying to
be shorter shorter questions so I was
thinking about it sort of that way a lot
of it so I knew like oh we like talking
about like the idea of marriage as a
subject I think was the thing and I
asked him about that and I remember that
was a sort of a sample type of thing I
do now which is you give a short answer
to a question that I wanted a longer
answer from right it's like someone will
in an interview say like really just
like could all can think we're Jerry's
like marriage is like the most
interesting thing in the world and then
able to sort of move on and then
whatever where I'm like we'll talk about
that or I mean it's like honestly it's
like a thing I learned from having a
therapist which is this sort of like
you'll answer something and they'll just
say like can you talk more about that
and it and I think it's like a really
useful interview text
technique in general which is don't let
a person like people sometimes are in a
rush to finish answering so just be like
no just keep like keep on going like
you're being interesting I'm going to
ask you know so it was a little bit of
that which is like I know he's
interested in this let's try to get him
talk about it longer and that and and
something's worked other than others the
example you brought about cherry stuff
I'm talking about his terrible thing to
talk about Ashok's is you know the rest
of the quote is something like but it's
really boring to these people right and
and that was a moment where I'm like
that's right I found it very annoying
like I its bird with me cuz it's like
traumatic obviously this is interesting
these people what I couldn't stay that
then I usually don't have like tons of
questions about it so it didn't matter
um but I also was doing other things
that festival so I couldn't like give
every single thing I had to it compared
compared to what I do now where it's
like I prepare them that's the only
thing I'm thinking about for as long as
I can think about it yeah and you've
said that you actually when you prepare
it you falling in love with the guest
and then the interview is like saying
what I love about them it's right well
that's a it's not telling the person I
love it through their face because I
think that'd be weird too that he's
trying to convey to the audience what is
lovable about them through my eyes I
guess it's probably a better way of
putting it like I want I you know it's
it's it's trying to leave people with
the perception of the person that I have
and you don't do the best you can but
like I think it's trying to see people
as I see them and the way you see a
person what different low for them so
it's like being it's an extreme amount
of empathy of like not being things that
might you might have a problem with
about them or oh you don't like this
part of the joke or you think this is
maybe hacky or just not that interesting
you still try to like love that part of
and try to have them expand upon in a
way that makes them seem interesting or
whatever and I think it's really about
you know it's it's helping people
understand how to appreciate comedians
better I guess a lot of it and
understanding they're all different
people with sort of like unique
sensibilities and ideas of what they're
trying to do one of my favorite
comedians Alonzo Bodden just did a Q&A
with us and he was talking about a lot
of people think comedy is talking but
it's actually listening and with
interviewing listening is something I've
had to work very hard on even to you
responding then and I'm looking for a
moment you said something about having a
therapist and then instead of me
listening to what's next I'm like oh but
should I find a place to shoehorn that I
researched that his dad's a therapist
and that he has a psychology degree at
Maryland but I should be listening to
what he's saying instead so like how how
do you stay in the moment or if Jerry
Seinfeld does say something like I I
like talking about jokes even though
these people think it's boring how do
you not then go off and be like oh
that's a show that's really gonna take
off you stay in the moment with him yeah
I think it's really interesting because
I would not call myself a great listener
as podcasters are or like interviewers
are supposed to be or tend to be I am a
very thorough planner or thinker I guess
would be which is you know as you you
know I how would I put it I have a good
sense of where the answers are going to
go even if they've never talked about it
before I have us whatever it is I have a
rhythm in my head and I you know I I
call it a storage driven interview and
so much is that I have an arc in which
we're trying to go and I have my brain
moves quick enough
the and I have a good enough memory of
everything that I was going to ask
because they are sort of natural
extensions of where the conversation
supposed to go that I'm able sort of
sort it out I mean when it's not when
it's not when it's audio only it's a lot
easier because you can just pause a
little bit and you could say well as I
can say and I have all the papers out
you know one
set up to do the interviews usually when
it's in person I have all my questions
typed out I have the joke typed out
usually I type I type out all the joke
or find someone or I'll have an intern
do it I don't find the process of typing
up the joke itself it's like revelatory
it's just sort of like it's useful to
have it so I can know which we're in the
joke anti-aligned was it all have the
research there even though I never look
at the printout of the research that I
do but it's like I need sort of a
certain amount of like scattered miss to
like be able to sort of focus in and and
it really is you know just trying to
trying to Judy I mean ultimately doing
two things at once I mean I think I just
say it's like yeah I think about what
happens in those moments you know like
in the Moshe kasher interview he jumped
ahead to a thing though suppose that was
going to ask like he was talking about
the thing I was gonna talk that happens
more than anything else which is someone
brings up a thing before I want them to
and then I have to decide if I want to
talk about that then or if it messes up
the flow and I bring it up later
and as I've been doing more of these I
I'm just getting quicker at deciding
that and thinking about what it means I
mean sometimes ivory edited the
interviews to go in the order where it
needed to go
well often I mean once I like you know
Marc Maron's his interviews are
completely edited ya know that you know
that into the thousand episode he did an
interview with his producer and they
explained that like his producer will
completely rearrange things if it's
necessary for the rhythm of it and I
don't do that huh because I because
because Marc essentially marc has no
plan so it's just sort of like instinct
also sometimes it works in without the
does of them because I have a plan I
don't need to do that but sometimes I
will do it if it is necessary and hey
one second
that was that boat no you're fine yeah
no worries at all no worries
alright great questions everyone keep up
keep commenting with them we're about to
jump into your questions
I'm just selfishly taking this time to
also ask him questions so keep
commenting with them and we're gonna get
to them and we appreciate you hanging
out with us I have too much faith in my
cat's ability to just chill and so I was
like you gotta it's all good rosebud
Baker had to like let her dog in and out
and it was no worries I think tone Bell
his dog in the first interview we did
together his dog was barking the whole
time like it's it's all part of it why
do you interviewed Maria Bamford her
dogs were there the first time I made it
big Maria Bamford for the podcast her
dogs were there and they were like one
was snoring and I thought was like I'm
Jude and then we kept we're like that's
fine and then my my producer that I had
at the time was like this is so annoying
okay I guess when you don't think the
dog it's like nah it's not you're very
distracting
well that was in the moment where I'm
like yeah that's right I have the dog
and I was like it poses like we gotta
take this dog out did you do it answer
request I don't think you took the dog
Wow okay
yeah but yes I was saying about being
yeah I mean it's just really really
knowing it's interesting cuz it's not
like I like reread my questions over and
over again I just sort of like have a
sense of where they are and the type of
thing they want to do and try to keep it
on track and feel like it's going in
order and if someone's jumping ahead
decide if oh this is too interesting
sounding to a listener that they're
gonna be like wait what is that
I need to know what he's talking right
now and if we distract me if I don't
bring it up or it's like oh they only
mentioned partly in in a mess of things
I can bring it up in a different context
later and say you know you said this
earlier because like ultimately like you
only have one question afterwards and
that's like the nature of how interviews
go so people understand you're gonna
bring up things people have said in you
know and since that's kind of what I do
anyway which is like you said this once
it's it's fine you know ultimately what
you're saying they said before I was
planning on acknowledging they said it
before so it doesn't really matter that
much you just sort of like have to relax
it like you have you already have the
story that you're gonna want to tell
this this reminds me of like epic bombs
of doing interviews I always ask
comedians on here their worst bombing
story but maybe for you what's an
interview and this could be from good
one or one you've done in the past where
everything goes wrong like I've had
interviews where like the SD card fills
up and then if it's over the phone the
phone drops then the batteries die like
I've had all of it go wrong what about
for you I mean I had I mean like add a
lot of technical difficulties with the
chelsea peretti one audio wise for like
other what like otherwise dinner it was
great I you know before good one I when
I was just like a guy who would
interview people as part of junkets
where they're doing 30 phone calls 15
minutes each and I'm one of them and
they don't know who you are they barely
heard what publication they're talking
to and to maintain any sort of sanity as
that you have to like not be a person so
I remember what I did Kevin Hart it was
the sort of the first time so this is
not for the podcast he's just sort of
like not there he it I was supposed to
interview him at like 4:30 on a Friday
but it kept on being pushed back and I
was talking now like 7:30 on a Friday
and
we only like 15 minutes they not to down
to 10 or whatever and then he just sort
of wasn't there and I don't for grudge
him I found it very frustrating but like
because and even that time I chose
trying hard to be interesting but he
just sort of couldn't be interesting in
that moment because he couldn't be like
at all present cuz he you try to like
dehumanize yourself when he was junkets
one eighth of you Kevin the other time
he was very busy but I was the only
interview he was doing like he was on
the set of Jumanji I was in his trailer
yeah leave in the middle to shoot a
scene and we picked it up but he was
there he gave me a lot of pods I think
Kevin's heart Kevin's brain moves very
quickly so he is a challenging interview
in some ways but like he was there and
he's present and he like tried hard
which is like not what you can say for a
lot of people specially that famous so I
feel like they want to be good in
interview so like that was one but since
I had good one they all they they all
work have worked I didn't like I think
by the time I got to more famous people
they had people I eat interview that
they respected on so they knew that this
was something to respect I don't know
what happened somewhere along the way
comedians decided to like treat me
nicely I think I've had some part time
with live episodes because certain
performers like feel the need to be the
persona when they do live episodes but
that those are the only ones where I'm
like oh I wish an I wish had more time
cuz live episodes tend to be a hard out
so um those are the only ones but you
know nothing where it's like ah where
I'm like I don't think we can release
that um yeah I'm trying to think if I'm
like I know I've had conversations like
we're gonna have to do some work to take
out the boring parts but like or it's
too long
fine even in nose I won't say which one
but there are certain people who sort of
like
Hawken ways and was like a lot of this
is very boring but a lot of it's very
interesting and I know my brain sparked
enough of like this is an interesting
thing to know there's interesting stuff
in there and I just like take out all
the boring parts and then it's fine and
you wouldn't know you've been in the
logit yeah I've done the same especially
with earlier interviews now I don't edit
interviews but early days I would edit
out a lot of the filler words my um zan
dogs and there are there were a few
interviews where I was like this could
be sped up this could be moved along a
little bit but now I just kind of keep
them as is thank you I mean like if we
can do it I mean it's I I don't edit
them because I do the editing in terms
of like the structure and I'm just like
I tell the producer network and
producers along the way it's like if
it's boring to you it's boring
there's enough stuff like as long as we
get to the end point that I wanted to
get to and and there's times I can't
remember which interviews but there's
times where I fish for endings to feel
full circle and I asked one I'm like
that's it but let me well I have enough
time let me ask this other thing and
they like it doesn't work and I'm like
take out the other thing and that's the
per yeah that's the perks of having a
producer this is a one-man band here so
it is how like I don't want to have to
spend another 15 hours on this episode
to myself and like think because every
to me like what I've heard the
information I kind of get bored if I've
done a full interview I'm like I already
know all this anyway but but the lizard
does it so I I'm always trying to
remember oh the listener hasn't listened
to 70 interviews with this person mmm
they might have like vaguely remember
would at most even if they're fans so I
tried to like and account for that that
part of it at least
okay so we've gone through almost the
entire arc of the interview here and
then we're gonna get into questions uh
now post interview I mean still we could
take this to the Jerry Seinfeld because
Guinea had talked to him as a person is
like I remember before the interview
he's
skinny are you nervous and he's kind of
poking at you it seems like he like it
seems like he enjoys to do with people
what about like post interviewed was
there conversation or was he just was he
gone he was great
I don't know if I probably haven't
shared this part of the story is much
because it comes off as bragging he he
loved he loved the interview his
publicist was like he hates doing press
and he loved doing that like immediately
she really enjoyed doing it he was
really nice to me he was really nice to
my family my family was there they took
he took pictures with all my family I
don't think I can must have taken a
picture of a he put he was just like
where you from oh and then he you know
he said like I always can't remember the
exact quote but I do probably bring it
up where he he said you're really
interested in jokes or you really care
about jokes or something like that and I
knew what he meant which was for like
for not a comedian I think you know
Jerry is a person who sort of like he
there's people that are comedians and
there's people who are not comedian and
he only likes comedians and if he likes
you you're now a comedian a little bit
like comedic cards of coffee has
comedians on it but I also will have
like his friends that are now comedians
because he thinks they're good and I I
think part of the reason I he I you know
I in the interview I proved that I was
with it but I was able to move things
along that I you know just like I got it
and I think he talked to so many people
who don't get it that he was just so
relieved you know and he wasn't there
long we weren't like hanging out but he
just really enjoyed doing it that's why
he allowed me to release as a podcast
like years later they're like Oh Jerry
want to do it you know they were like as
long as it doesn't preclude him doing
the podcast at a later time which we
still haven't set up would be happy to
do I mean who knows I mean like he had
especially didn't feel like doing a lot
of press around it so we didn't do it I
mean maybe I'll you know I'll tea has a
book coming out I'll try to do around
the book but me too then
I'll reach out to his publisher
- then that's the time yeah I mean like
he really cares about Tom be like a lot
yeah I think he I think he I invite I
mean it was five years ago and already
the discourse has changed but he was
still coming from a time where it seemed
like no one cared anything at all about
comedy and I think he's aware now that
people do so I look I ain't movin to be
like I remember camera just came over
the interview or just in general where
he's like I think you'd want to do a
masterclass if I had a guess of like
what he'd do with this rate I'm like I
think you really want to teach comedy II
you know I interviewed Jeff Garlin I was
talking to him about something but it is
either something Chris Rock said or
something Jerry Seinfeld said because
that's the thing with I think it's like
that thing with Jerry and Chris Rock -
they they have these rules but they
think are like that there's like
freaking kings of all like they both in
it you know especially Jerry like has
all these ideas of what common should be
and I think you'd have opportunity to
like talk about a space where he doesn't
think he has to appeal to sort of like
the mass audience that he had so much
he's already appealed to so much that I
think you know like appreciate just like
oh I'm free to be as boring as I want to
be perfect
so let's let's jump into questions I've
been I've been selfishly holding up this
time asking my own questions we will let
fans and we call our hot breath averse
we call us all hot brethren and sister
in here so let's get to their questions
so Gregory Hardy asks hi Jesse when
you're finding yourself chatting with a
comic in the real world as a post on
your show do you have go to conversation
icebreakers or something you want to
know especially if it's someone you're
meeting for the first time I mean I'm
not like a chatty person so in some ways
no like I don't just like talk to people
you know if I'm meeting a person first
time in an unstructured setting I'm just
not going
talk to them unless I've already
interact with them the like on Twitter
or whatever and then like oh we've
already interact on Twitter I'm this
person um but so my most chatting is
like when they first come to do the
podcast and I'm like hi I'm the person
thank you for doing the show I'll tell
them what it is but to answer their
question ultimately when I do find
myself in a time to chat with them like
to pee it afterwards you know I have a
certain amount of gossip because I know
a lot of comedians like tangentially so
like you know can we just like like to
gossip a lot and they like to talk about
like it's like why are they talking
trash but it's a lot of just like this
person got this opportunity why do you
think that is like I have certain amount
of insights on the industry they take a
lot of comedians don't have it I can be
like oh this is why they've got this is
worried about that that's what I heard
about this person this is why this
person I heard this word it's hard to
work with so it's who who now that's the
thing I mean like anyone can be there's
there's only so many people who are easy
to work with and that means their
disorders like so competent so and so
easily capable that like they have time
to be nice and and present with
everybody most people are not that
confident in their abilities and already
so talented that they could not just
have to focus other work so it my pated
almost no one's easy to work with
most people are difficult in some ways I
mean life if you have an opinion about
how things are you're gonna be in a
situation where someone has a different
opinion and then you're immediately
difficult to work with and obviously
that is also like the idea of being
difficult is also tend to be incredibly
the people who tend to be you how do I
put this there are certain people get
let off the hook a lot easier for being
difficult work with and I think we'd
like one men white men are deemed
difficult to work with it's like they
get to be geniuses not like difficult
actresses are in the same way so a
you're aware
said in a gossip situation you could
talk about all the stuff you want doctor
so that's what I tend to do I don't ask
them about comedy you know we'll ask
them like were they doing in town if
they need restaurant recommendations or
whatever but on the basics like I'm not
I'm not like chit-chatting if I like see
a comedian I sort of like barely know
cool and this ties into the next one
when we talk about meeting comics with
this is from I'm Marie he asks do you
get nervous in the past interviewing
these penis people and how do you calm
your nerves
yeah I mean I used to get really nervous
before I interviewed anybody I and it
felt
I get nervous when I talk to anyone that
I'm gonna mess up like I don't like
talking on the phone usually because
like that anticipation I relate our time
with and that was really up until the
point
and I interviewed Jerry and then once I
got through that and once I went well I
was like well if I can do that I can do
that with sort of anyone like if I can
get through that and what I started to
realize is like and this is the case
often I think also with stand-up which
is sort of like nervousness and
excitement are the same feeling it just
sort of how you're coding it so like I
am still feeling the feeling of nerves
but I understand like that as part of
what is exciting especially for life
it's so many things can go wrong but
then once I might stage it's fine you
know like I think with anything I get to
the point room like well it's too late
now is what I'll say like sue Lee now to
back up I have to do it and so that is
sort of that carries me through and then
once you're on it you're doing it you
realize like they have to answer the
questions there they have the harder job
I already did all the work is what I say
to myself you already did a little work
you're you already wrote the question
job they're here you're just gonna say
these out loud and so that that was a
lot of it I think with the podcast I was
nervous the show would be
bad and I'm like how do I make it not
bad all this is gonna be boring you know
every moment I was nervous as can be not
interesting and that in that big median
to be really stressful or tense or the
opposite would happen where it's kind of
my nerves come so much that I would be
like this is now not interested to do
this I'm like worried no everything and
that changed one eighth of you diese
some arrow because they were so fun and
so fast and so present that I'm like oh
yeah this show is fun that's like why I
did it that's what the listeners like is
that I'm there to have fun and like the
listeners like do enjoy having me be a
surrogate to be appreciating these
people like I remember was he in every
neighbor got ciose I was nervous or just
like feeling like oh no how's it gonna
go and I was like I think this guy talks
funny he when he talks either good sound
sweaty he is a funny cadence literally
just listen to it and then so it and
that's sort of what I did which I was
like I could take in that energy and I
try to like figure out how to make it
into excitement and like have that and
not be afraid of being excited like
having people had to hear that
oh that's funny it's similar to like
being a comedian like if you're having
fun on stage the audience will have fun
so it's fun how that translates yeah I
mean that is one of the better trends of
the last 20 years of comedy comedians
were allowed to have good stage mm so
we're like that was like tapes repeal
was like I think really big I was like
laughing at himself I can't remember
comedian before him that laughed himself
so much and was also considered good
like like his cohort and like if you
look at like a lot of the like New York
school like killer type people they're
like you gotta be serious and like angry
at the crowd or whatever right and and
you're like why who's that for like I
know it's like Rudin and all these ideas
are like toughness but it's like I think
if Dave Chappelle
didn't find himself on stage his he's
like entire persona would fall apart and
like you see that with everybody I mean
like if you can naturally organically
convey joy not force it like but
actually organically convey that to a
level like if you I mean like Chris and
Charles like may one the greatest ever
at it like it is truly infectious and
like part of your job is to make people
feel better like like being funny
broadly defined is the goal and being
interesting what like part of it is like
people are trying to have fun like that
is a laugh mmm-hmm fun is not like not
antithetical to the goal would be a
comedian yeah I just did a special
review of Chris Delia's new special and
was looking at how he uses smiling and
laughing as almost tags to his material
it's very powerful and effective yeah I
mean it it's it's I mean it's partly
persona comedy right it's like
ultimately by the time to get big enough
people like want to just hang out with
you hmm
so like they want you to just be
yourself on stage and you don't have to
and certain comedians care about that
more than other certain people like I'm
fine getting whatever I can get like I
worked my entire life to get fans let me
give them what they want where some
people I think resent their fans or
don't don't accept easy laps from their
fans or they try to forget you know it's
it's a balance it's really hard like you
need fans to allow yourself to push
yourself more to do you have fans media
have a more patient audience which is
useful because that means you can do
something more interesting but they also
it's really forgiving and it allow you
to sort of like do nothing so it that's
always what I find it fascinating when I
talk to comedians what's a relationship
to their audience is and how it changes
and works out at different points it's
probably it's one of like the many
things I probably ask every commedia bat
in a certain way all right so let's wear
it 45 minutes right now can we do like
through two more questions yeah oh
that's great yeah everyone quarantined
yeah it's been yeah we've just been
throwing some Hail Marys for these q and
A's like I was that's why I asked you
about booking guests
because I'm like I'm just gonna start
reaching out to like Seinfeld and like
Tom papa and and like Sinbad and just
shoot for the moon here I mean the I try
to think about who might have a mic cuz
they do you know the audio quality
without a mic for us is hard and but if
people are also actors or like script
writers they still are busy that is if
that is the one thing like or they are
they're saving their press I mean like
there are certain people have been able
to get that are like excited to do it
because it's all they're trying to do
this week but you know some people are
parents right so they are like you have
to think about if if because they're
comedian that means their job during
this time is to be a full-time parent
like all that stuff is is things that
you have to think about of like okay how
am i factoring down to this person's are
trying to get through this okay so let
me try to amalgam eyes these because we
have people asking somewhat of the
similar questions so what we'll do is
we'll combine these two Kyle groom and
chase Bonin asking the same things in
terms of well one what's your favorite
comedy album or special and also pretty
much like what's your favorite joke if
you could take a joke from a comedian
and make it your own what would it be
my favorite special or album you know
you know it varies so it's hard I mean
like Christian shawls my favorite
comedian her live at Bolton of live at
the Fillmore special was really
meaningful to me
I saw her work on it because I really
liked their time and then what you saw
which was the sort of Ike
really mixture of sort of like an Andy
Kaufman East stunt the sort of blending
of real life and and stage persona but
also this idea of joy all at the same
time I was really special and inspiring
it like this is like this was probably
seven years ago before like a lot of
people were working hard to have
interesting specials but now people are
like thinking hard about like what their
comedy is and what they want to do even
like people who you think of is like not
intellectual comedians are like trying
to think about like oh it should be shot
in this style for this reason but this
was like a really early case of someone
like treating the special adds a visual
art form and like an experiment Anna has
lots of funny jokes and it's so silly
and like a specific voice so that is
probably my favorite special I mean like
Kyle Kinane makes people probably
laughed the most but his specials tend
to be a little bit limited because
they're comedy central's that they added
them really really tightly and like just
sort of the cadence of his jokes I can't
hold him a sort of all blur so I don't
know which ones the start of my favorite
but his first album death of the party
was really seminal to me getting back
into comedy that and Hannibal's first
sample my name is Hannibal whatever
really seminal to me like I had like a
eight year lull or whatever I like was
not into comedy as much and those those
albums came out I saw them live most
like they're amazing um my favorite joke
I feel like I used to have an answer
like I have
I don't know I mean I have so many that
I just rapid-fire go through jokes I
think about often because um Mitch
Hedberg is joke why I once all why no
eating a grape I said man you have to
wait I try to do know mr. forget it man
you have to wait yeah I was like I
couldn't I I couldn't just like that the
world he created oh now remember I do
have an answer for my favorite joke
so but there's that Michael because joke
called Casa chuse it's about his which
does the thing that I is so credible
when a community can do this and not a
lot of people can't do it which is build
the structure in a joke where by the end
of it it feels like an inside joke and
he's he's the best at it
he probably second best at it like oddly
enough his Hannah Gatsby but she does it
differently and she's very clever about
it so what I often say is my favorite
joke is from the Roseanne Barr roast
Anthony Jeselnik had a joke which was
you know Roseanne or a tyrant or
something when you know when he worked
on Roseanne everyone everyone walked on
eggshells around you cuz you would not
stop eating eggs and what I love about
that joke I'm like I asked Anthony about
it he was sort of like I didn't even
think twice about that joke but what I
what I loved about it was it just sort
of is so visual and such a small thing
mm-hmm and like I love how gross jokes
can paint these worlds in such small
amounts of words and I always loved that
like when jokes know like iceberg so you
could sort of tip of it and
that one felt like there's just so much
to the sort of like world he's painting
in that Joe there's a million more but
that is the one I think I often say is
my favorite joke just cuz I also like
can remember it and complete we're like
I know I love Nate Burkett sees dead
horse joke but like I can't remember the
whole thing but you had even not only
did you know the joke but you had great
timing within it to like you had the
pacing that be you cannot you could not
stop eating it was just like yeah it was
I mean his persona so odd like he his
sort of take his cadence is easy to come
right but you were had you held back on
the mitch hedberg one but then Anthony
Jeselnik you could fall into but you
know because I don't know why it is I
think I'd probably as I've been telling
the mixture longer so I have sort of
like started telling it out loud without
doing with the Kate it where I'm telling
and every time we do the just like joke
I do with the Kate mmm-hmm because I do
it there are makes jokes I could do I
mean like you just know it I think it's
sometimes funny to not do it with the
cadence and see what it still is as a
joke but the other one I always think of
is a I had a friend to come up for me it
goes guess what I love mashed potatoes
like man you got to give me a chance to
guess what egg he was such a like you
know for as much as he's thin he thought
it was a one-liner it's like such a
persona and like rhythmic comedian oh my
gosh yeah he's one of the Sinbad's the
comic that in sparked the idea to become
a comedian for me with a frozen Bell
Bobby really oh yeah the onesie and the
earring like I was his that the fun like
you were talking about he has fun on
stage he's seeing him have fun on stage
and that special was like oh that looks
fun I'd like to do that and then you
know it takes several years to actually
decide to pursue your dream but that's
what planted the seed I think was it
partly that he was clean or is it that
you just saw it like I always wonder
what Sinbad like I I know a lot of
people like he was the only comedian
that a lot of people got to watch
because he was clean and famous
the nineties well I am a I'm a clean
comedian now which was like a conscious
decision starting out is that we just
wanted to be clean so I could entertain
more people like Brian Regan or like a
Sinbad but at the time I think I was
just younger and it just look like he
was having fun and there was like a you
know his specials had like a theme going
on behind it he was dressed crazy so he
just made it look like a fun activity
and not just standing with a mic stand
you know just projected and you got to
interview him I'm I'm in talks with him
we've been going back and forth but we
haven't nailed it down yet yeah he's hot
he's you can't keep him down like that
she'd know that about him if you listen
to another podcast he just goes he can
hang with anybody it's incredible I
don't know if you listen to the podcast
Hollywood handbook but it's a very
insular word a lot of people go on and
they can't hang and he's just like
jumped in like his part of the show and
he's but his brain is so quick that you
don't need to be there and to me that is
not an interesting interview so like if
you have to be really conscious like
stop do a follow up question because
he'll move on and you won't actually get
it ahead sir mmm he's wild he's he just
move his brain moves so quickly and like
the way comedians talk about seeing it
it's like wild here's the first comedian
that I ever saw really yeah when I was
in I went to a family trip to Las Vega
I don't know what the person means but
like of course can be nice all live yeah
we watch on family we saw him and I only
remember like a joke II did that wasn't
very good but I couldn't remember
anything else about the show I have no
sense of how long it was I know like I
liked it but yeah it just Wyatt he's
always I think he you know I think he's
too proud oh come back I think people
are ready for him
oh and he's known to improvise a lot
like he's known to always do a different
show and always mix it up which is
something that I strive to do but I
still get caught now I've been doing
comedy ten years but I I still can get
like the math and structure of comedy
but now I think I just I just released
my first special and I think getting
that material out there has freed me up
to follow that instinct more on stage of
being a little more in the moment but
now there's a pandemic that kind of just
I released the special on February 1st
it was my ten year anniversary and then
like I'm like oh here we go now we're
gonna start open field running again and
then now it's just like oh we're back
we're stuck here now so yeah I mean I
think it's an interesting period for
every comedian but I think you in that
case of like I think after people put
out their first anything which is like
here's a collection of what the audience
told me I should do and like throughout
the years I did a bunch of things and
this is what the audience said they
liked and sometimes there you'll be
brilliant like you'll have a vision and
coincidentally like like the comedians
put you in a box and that box was what
we call genius but often it just like
these are what they thought was good and
I was just trying to hang and now it's
the time where you're like well actually
like what I want to say and why do I
want to say it and what is the goal that
I wanted to get for a minute like I now
know I could put together an hour of
thing that people find funny which is
like heart that's part of the job or it
can be but it's like well now all I
decided I want to be like great at this
thing and post being good at it I want
to be great at this layton well then you
need time to like what is actually what
I want to do and that's hard some people
can never do that
I think there's I think people
especially it happens a lot in New York
because there's so many shows that you
can kind of Li just get in a flow like
10 minutes 10 minutes 10 min tour
constantly doing stuff about New York
City and you do stuff about like topical
stuff and like it's interesting to do
topical and it's in the moment but like
if you're just responding you're never
asserting who you want to be and but you
can maybe find that on the stage but
part of that just means becoming an
interesting person mm-hmm we're being a
person that like has a believer like
what they
what the world - sort of like what what
world are trying to convey and I think
it's good I think I hope comedians use
this time to like well now that I'm not
depending on the audience let me just
like think about what the what things do
I have I not talked about that I like
are actually novel like especially cuz
everyone's gonna come back now these
pandemic jokes
you have the opportunity of not doing
that so yeah you know like even if
you're not like a pen and paper person
like think about you know different
things and what have you not seen people
do that you feel like should be talked
about I'm always looking for the
contrast or the inverse of what
seemingly works for people in everything
I do and that was something with like
the comedy special everyone's trying to
like sell them to a network or a
platform to get on I was like what
happens if you do it independently and
then try to sell it all yourself and do
that and I'm always looking for just
like with this podcast comedians are
doing podcast well how could I do it
differently Oh instead of trying to out
funny the guest I'll just do well
thought out researched interviews always
looking for like a inverse to what the
trend seems to be so it'll pay off in
like 20 years
yeah I mean I think about it constantly
it's just like it will be really
interesting you know there's a lot of
comedians who talk about 9/11 really
motivating them and he saw like a
generation of really good comedians that
came about like about 10 years around
2011 you're seeing like what we think of
it's like a huge wave of great comedians
and it's like all after 9/11 all these
people are like Todd Rock should pursue
my dreams and he had more people doing
it which meant more points of view which
meant like more people pushing each
other like everything became harder and
you just got you know what it was a boom
of like incredibly good comedian and now
just keep them going which is nice but
like these moments are thing that it can
remind people
like do work with integrity do do work
with a fourth purpose and I and I think
that is a thing that gets lost a lot for
comedians because you're so much of it
is trying to keep your head above water
what do you think the effect coronavirus
will have on comedy moving forward I
don't know I mean it's it pies possibly
know when it will start again I mean
there's people really would like to see
live comedy right now and I think but
can't lease in New York especially but
and that dynamic is interesting just
like people gonna come back and they're
going to really excited to do it and I
think the it's hard I mean it's also
like depends on how the election goes
you know like not it not even like
regards about political it is it just
sort of like it the elections are gonna
be in anyone's mind it's like this can
be all that but like in a year
depending on how the election goes it it
it will shape it I mean ticket I'm for
example I'm like I bring this up because
I'm like literally working at a book
proposal and part of it it's like I'd be
saying like I will not submit this book
is not done until at least a year after
the next inauguration cuz like I you
need that time to sort of look back up
on it but I you know this is what I hope
which is comedians and all comedian that
audiences it's a sort of like distance
makes the heart grow fonder
and they sort of remember that they're
doing this for each other like this
comedians want the audience to have a
good time and they want to be
deferential to like what their what
would be how make them feel better or
like what is useful for them it's just
sort of it's hard to describe but like I
I think there's a certain vernacular the
comedians have for audiences like the
killing and destroying all that stuff
which I get but that is bill
out of a time period that does not exist
anymore in which comedian where
audiences are bad and that audiences are
stupid and audiences don't know what
good comedy is that was like that
vernacular came out of the 80s when like
there was no comedy literacy whatsoever
or commie savvy and comedian succeeded
in spite of their audiences and that
cynicism still exists and I understand
why but like there's so many people who
know more about comedy than ever before
who wanted good comedy and are like who
want something from comedians and I
think comedians have taken that for
granted and I think audiences have been
there are certain audiences that I think
are impatient with comedians in a way
that they shouldn't be or what are
comedians to be the same thing what I
think they should be and I hope when
reunited everyone just sort of isn't
patient with each other hmm like a joke
bombs don't be like you guys are wrong
you guys are idiots would you see all
the time right it's like the audience is
always right the comedian's always right
like we're figuring this out together
it's a collaboration it is a special
we're talking about state of it stand-up
jokes are a collaboration to the
audience and the comedian is a saint of
joke without an audience it's not a
stand-up joke it is a different thing
that's what we all agree upon what this
is and it should be more of a we should
accept as a sort of collaborative
atmosphere it's like people don't talk
about alt comedy and Club comedy as much
anymore
but I think the thing that was always
lost about like what is good about a
club an alternative community is the
community aspect which is like this
feeling that the audience is part of the
process that is what can make sense is
what makes it up special so like why are
we turning our back on that but like
this is the medium that truly is
collaborative like jam bands pretend
they are in jazz as they are or whatever
but not really you're still like kind of
responding to a vibe we're like
literally material is defined by what
the audience says works
so that's what I hope I don't know if
that'll happen I mean it's possible that
like everyone will just be really scared
and like no one gets any laughs but I'm
an idealist Princeton and this is sort
of like when I dream of what comedy is
it's like this sort of utopia where like
it's like we're all a sort of commune of
like creating this art together that was
beautiful that was beautiful
I'm gonna put that on a plate and glaze
it and then hangry it'll be a platter so
on the inverse of positivity actually
this is a positive spin though with a
cerium asking what is your concept of
failure and how do you take setbacks my
personal ass idea or oh yeah your
personal let me think it's how do I
think about failure I mean I I don't
feel particularly entitled to a lot so I
don't expect I'll you know I'm not
optimistic in terms of my expectations
for myself so I I sort of don't get lit
down on personal things than that in
that way sort of where everything else
beyond myself I sort of had these like
grand beliefs of what things should be
like and I get incredibly disappointed
when things don't live up to it but I
sort of like you know this was all the
third option of a career III I was
trying to work in the music business
like writing was a accidental byproduct
of me trying to work in the music
business and try to work in the events
business and earnestly trying to work
hard for that and it just like dated
work I was not a good fit for that
industry they didn't like me I know I
tell the story laughs but I got let go
from working at a major agency William
Moore nice you're just way more I was
too sensitive to work
you're too sensitive work here you're
too much of an intellectual live in Los
Angeles he's like get out of here get
out of town there's what he says so I
feel incredibly fortunate that I get to
do this anything around this like I am I
think I I'm not below look beyond
privilege that I have like these niche
interests niche niche abilities and the
marketplace has deemed them valuable so
like I've had certain opportunities that
we're trying but I sort of like just
keep on doing like I realize along the
way like I used to be motivated by like
feelings meeting for legacy and stuff
like that and and wanting to leave a
mark or whatever and then somewhere
along the way I just sort of like
accepted that I enjoyed the work like
and I I said that's a sort of anybody
about like what should motivate you I
mean you can do what you ever can't do
and motivate to put me to put like you
are happier if you're motivated by the
work than the results of the work so
once I realized I like what I'm doing as
long as I keep on getting to do it I
sort of am NOT incredibly worried or
credibly affected by a setbacks because
I'm still getting to do it you know like
I am a podcast that I have a career
getting to do then I have complete
control over what it is that is more
than most people who are creative get to
say about the things that they're doing
like I didn't do enough comedians to
know that they have to compromise to get
certain sort of things when they create
TV show or whatever and that sucks and
they want more things they can control
why already have a career doing that
thing so I think that is whatever I buy
myself with I don't get down I'm a
pretty medium person so I don't get
particularly up uh-hum terms of my mood
I do not get like crazy excited I like
from I never got to attend I don't
usually get to
usually between 4 & 6 often at four so
that doesn't really help but in terms of
what the advice would be you would be
like as long as you like doing it and or
not like it's even the same thing with
before I got a career writing I was like
I like writing I at least have a hobby
for the rest of my life
I think people like or not we I don't
know when we decided hobbies are not
allowed and that we can't they can't be
meaningful hmm but like if you have up
if you like have a means of expression
but it's not what you get paid to do
like that is a 100% okay that it's like
what most people did there's a lot of
great artists who did it as like their
side gig like just like will remind
yourself that you're doing because you
like creating it and then the failure of
it is doesn't matter as much because
that's not like why you're doing it I
love it
oh and Carter Carter Ashton Bryant says
love Goodwin so we're gonna spread the
love here thank you
so yeah Carter astron Faber Bryant he
actually booked me in Arkansas last year
actually he's been a member of the
hopper at the first for several years I
wouldn't name that's solid yeah well I
mean Jesse David Fox you know that's a
strong name that's quite a yeah I mean
but his name is like all last name it is
like it does have it sort of like setup
punchline II think I'm like - Dead -
Dead mm-hmm why why why I mean first one
buy it for SEO reasons but lasting yeah
I mean and then like it won't buy us Bo
regions and then I had a roommate it was
almost 10 years ago it was like I was
like it doesn't sound too pretentious
like it's okay to be pretentious you're
trying to be a writer I was like yeah
and then I kick it sort of word you
think that's make me see that I am oh
you a your your
tastemaker you know I mean you're an
authority in this industry so I mean you
give a right to think your opinion
matters because it really does and it
moves yeah I'm out this in a lot of ways
well literally that's not true because
like people have agreed to I employ me
to write those opinions and people like
oh thank you for this opinion this is
very useful and I try to I mean like
that is you know that I did recently why
did that list of stand-up
recommendations I was like I need a mate
I was like this has to be useful and I
want to use my authority not to tell
people like what's good or bad but like
I know I can see comedy enough ways of
like I can make people find comedians
they wouldn't think to listen to because
how people recommend recommend how
people work my comedy think is
tremendously lacking mmm so you know I
guess I I don't take my authority
lightly is what I would say and how is
that response been in the actual
industry because this ties into Justin
Williams question who actually said my
full name is Justin Phillip Gordon
Patrick Williams so yeah they're all
strong his question ties into your
influence in the industry and I'd also
like to know a tag on the inverse of
this but he says have you gone to comedy
clubs or got to sit in the greenroom
getting the VIP treatment and I would
also think of like the opposite where
have you gotten well they're like oh you
don't like my special I am not worth the
list things like that so like have you
seen both sides of that yeah I mean I I
have never really read it much negative
and that is not because I don't have
negative pains I just sort of like I'm
not good at it I don't think my opinion
about what I think is not good is
interesting as much as I think of things
that's failings so I think there's so
much like what I didn't write them into
reviews which is I love taking myself of
the critic too much but
don't have my really wrote things that
give us some people so big that I think
it was built on the understanding we
already know that they're good so like I
can write things negative a hypothetical
Bob states repel because like there's a
certain amount of understanding of like
who were already is I don't know I've
never met Dave Chappelle I can't imagine
he has much interest I'm like friendly
enough with a meal or people who like
Dave Chappelle I've had comedians talk
to me about things I think I wrote about
Dave Chappelle which was interesting
conversations is a sort of like I wrote
a negative thinking about a show the
like it's hard to read this because I
saw a person killing and I'm like yeah
but you have it's hard for comedians
this is one of the harder things for
comedian to understand which is like
just because like people are laughing
does that mean you're doing a good job
like you're doing the job but like I was
talking to how to galaxy how
controversial she is and she has a story
about seeing Jim Jeffries tell these
really harsh jokes about lesbians and
being in the audience for that and
laughing because she's you're compelled
because you're part of an audience but
also like it's more you feel more safe
to laugh than to not laugh like a so
there's a bit of that which is like oh
just because it's laughing actually
might be doing a bad job
it means York like having people laugh
at jokes they don't agree with not
because you're doing something magical
that you're just sort of manipulating
the audience in a way that is like less
artful and more just sort of like peer
pressure I'll say I don't know once
confronted me we're like you're said
something me oh I I only go to green
room if I know them kind of well there's
not tons of comedians who I like say are
my friends um like any of them wanting
to do say are my friends like I will
more likely say a lot of them afterwards
then like hang out during the show the
the and also I don't want comedians to
know that I'm there hypothetically
because I don't know I think it'd be so
weird if they did crab work know like
hey what do you do for a living I'm
I'm one of these people but the closest
is if I do for festivals if they do my
pockets at festivals I will be then in
the mix and that I sort of like will
hang out with people in those contacts I
mean probably the closest was a went
backstage and Montreal for roast battle
and I like was in the greenroom talking
like Jeff Ross was like a lot of famous
people and I was like in the mission
yeah but it's I didn't know like I it's
not that it's like only for journalistic
integrity reasons of like oh I can't be
friends with comedians how would I be
able to report from it's only like I
don't like talking to people that I
don't know really
my night is don't want to sit around and
be awkward like then you you know I
don't want people like what are you
doing here like I think that is the
bigger reason you know like people want
to hang out with their friends they're
cool nice so let's just two more here
dos mas it's and this one we can
actually let me see if I can answer this
one and maybe if you have its I he's
asking I'm Ruiz asking have you ever
tried stand-up now you tried it once you
got it laughs realized okay I'm not the
Laughing like all these comedians I'm
glad I got out of my system but I'll
just stick to officiating weddings is
that the gist is there anything I'm
leaving out with your stand-up
experience yeah I mean I think the truth
is before I did stand-up ayah done story
reading things as a writer in New York
get asked to do and I try to write those
as funny as possible like I think the
more relevant question is a have I tried
to like do things funny like because yes
I did stand-up once I don't think it was
too revelatory to my process as a
interviewer or understand her of comedy
where'd you do it Ike where was do that
uh camera in the name of it it was like
this shown Greenpoint it was just like
it was just like oh it wasn't like a
club or anything okay now gotcha
it's a place that had Kali but like but
like I have been trying to create comedy
in different forms for as long as I
really have been a writer I mean like I
got into writing as like a blogger
primarily so like blogging is writing it
is like essentially writing it's joke
writing it is having a premise
articulating premise blah blah writing
punchline I like written scripts I've
written plays that have played for
audiences and so I I have experience
with sort of inner workings of writing
comedy and my own personal relationship
to how to think about it and that I
think is necessary for me as an
interviewer is to be able to think about
what creating feels like and the
weighing things manifest and sort of a
relationship between having a big idea
and having small ideas and how they
relate like oh I want this piece to be
about I don't know connectivity and then
but like ultimately it's like a
workplace comedy about whatever or you
want to be a fast like that is like
what's the job so if a-- comedy writing
is is sort of like how can i tell a
story or how can do something that is
small ideas that small story that is
about a bigger thing without having to
point a red sign that says like this is
the bigger idea you can do that i think
it's less graceful i think there is
effect to that i think a lot of people
prefer that because they like to know
what the thing is about but like if you
watched Jerry Seinfeld's most recent
special as an example certainly the
first half like I think a lot of people
dismiss Jerry's I hope it's like just
writing jokes about nothing like writing
jokes about small say
and rank joke about food or like these
mini school topics and there's no
substance behind it where if you are
open to it like Jerry Seinfeld is a
deeply existential comedian like he's
not writing about nothing as in like no
things he is writing about nothing he's
writing about nothingness he's renting a
house the meaninglessness of what we put
me to get - hmm man he is underlining it
he goes like these words that we decided
matter
look how meaningless their meaning is
they are so flexible to a point that it
is nothingness like all of his jokes are
about the things we decide to put value
and that actually have no real value and
and it's like I mean it's like it is
like any great existentialist work but
he is not saying I'm an existentialist
this is my show it's called waiting for
Jerry dough or whatever mmm more like
some play it's just like he's able to
sneak that in and I think that it's
really beautiful and that is a thing
that it's by creating you sort of have
that relationship and I think a lot of
critics think of what they do as
creating in the same way and I think of
the interview as a show that I'm
creating for the story that I'm telling
ya so when as a result that meet them
exposed to the type of things that sort
of creative people that are exposed to I
don't think like having to do stand-up
would speed what I need to do which
comedians have asked me before and I
often say like my job is not to
understand
comedians better so I think I understand
comedians about it to best be able to
under Canadian to audiences and that
means I need to be closer to the
audience than the comedian so I spending
years as a comedian I don't think what
actually make me better because then you
sort of build some sort of cynicism for
whatever that I don't think would be
useful so that is an incredible audience
crypt answer your short question
I don't plan on doing it again I haven't
you know I have done more story thing
someone's asked me to do one in
quarantine I don't know if I will
because as I think a lot of comedians
have realized like telling jokes about
audience it's like actually it's really
embarrassing feeling so I don't know
yeah but you you do have humor that you
can weave in to good one and like blade
Frank had tagged it up he brought up
like the laughing round you know I mean
and is it is it impossible not to laugh
when you're explaining it to a guest
yeah that was just incredibly early on
that was that for the most part the show
was what I thought was gonna be at the
beginning except more I didn't think
comedians were gonna give me so much
time or give me so much so I wanted the
interview be short I didn't want it to
be like so helping of the person was and
I realized that is actually separate
part of what what's in the show but once
I had the idea for the laughing round
the name regardless of like what it
would be it's when I was like this show
is me that's what I like really embrace
the show because like otherwise the show
felt like an only sort of captured how
serious I was or how thoughtful it was
or how happy I was and that was part of
me but I felt like I think of myself as
a particularly silly person I made a
particularly stupid person and and and
they and I wanted the show to sort of be
able to represent more of me and that
contrast I think is really funny so so
every time I do it I know the comedian
doesn't know it's gonna happen and it
comes at the most unreasonable time
because I asked them usually the most
serious thing they say sort of this like
oh hopefully some beautiful poignant
thing that ties everything together and
then like now I see some dumb pun that
doesn't really work it's so confusing to
them it's not funny to most of them like
some people like it a lot but very few I
feel like you like
Tim Minchin really liked it but most
people were like nothing which is the
funny some people like play along
against the joke is bad so they
underline the joke as bad and some
people like laugh cuz they know that I
know the difference Beth but when I get
nothing it's so funny mmm cuz there's
like um so that's money that I don't
know and it's funny when I Bears to do
it because I know they won't like it
like I knew chelsea peretti would hate
it or I know Natasha Leggero hated I
think when I said it cuz she hadn't
listened to the motion episode before
she agreed to do it and I knew when I
said it it was just like not cool and
her whole figure that she's cool
so I knew she wouldn't like it and she's
like oh I guess I didn't think I didn't
know we did this part was like yeah I
know you did it though because you
wouldn't agree you know I was
embarrassed to say with Marc Maron you
know cuz he's just like these cool
people so that adds a new but then once
I realize that people like it then it's
nice and I'm like oh this is the thing
that people like then like I don't think
I'm I'm not I don't try to over out join
these comedians in terms of how funny I
am and I think there is something the
contrast to me it's just like funny in
the app check regardless if it's like
will make you laugh it's just like
here's this person who has thought more
about coffee than anyone you could
imagine and then like this is the lesson
they learned is this joke all of it is
very funny to me um and yeah and then it
just sort of like the rhythm of doing it
I take it just like I'm so happy it's
there because otherwise it the show
would just be like so serious and so
unaware itself that like I'm not aware
that this is like first you know like I
think comedy is a hard time with
earnestness and pretentiousness for
obvious reasons and like to be just like
non-stop earnest would feel like out of
step with what comedy is and I and I
think that's what like reminds me of
like you know
oh we're still aware like what is like
the job of comedy or what is the tone of
comedy or like it's just sort of like I
think it punctures a certain balloon and
having it be every episode I think make
it so that I don't seem like some weirdo
who like doesn't think comedy is funny
is and only like tasted it's like sacred
text mmm
kaboom and the final question from Wayne
flake junior and he asks as a podcaster
okay a podcast question says as a
podcaster what is one major don't do and
one major do do and how he giggled it do
do and how how can Joel make hot breath
podcast the most respected comedy
interview podcast behind Goodwin I may
have added that last one sure I mean
it's hard I mean you have to know what
your show is right so like if your show
is not doing research it
your research would be really weird I
mean like I think it's so I you know I
want I feel like you want to short into
this of like don't like do work hard
[Music]
okay don't look the same type of person
over over again I think that is a
problem with comedy in general I think
it is a common a problem you'll see
often with comedy podcast which is if
you book the same type of person over
over again they become less interesting
and and same thing with shows like and
it's not like I always said part of the
goal was to show the intro diversity in
comedy and like diversity people like
only see often here one way which is
like Oh different races or whatever but
I'm not gonna like all sorts of
diversities different types of comedians
who do different types of things to do
different types of jokes
also who have different backgrounds
because like if you just have like ten
straight white male comedians do tell
like ironic edgy jokes dad with the same
cadence none of them will seem
interesting
but one of those people will sound
interesting if you have them in the
middle of a storyteller and a person who
sings song and a person who were like
right sketches like and I think you'll
see that that a lot of podcasts pocket I
respect don't try to do that they don't
try not to do that I think a lot of them
go like hey these are my friends these
are the people I can get and it's like
work harder like actually think about
who your guests are think about the
order of your guests
like I don't dismiss it like I actually
think about how they're sick your
audience wants to be find people
interesting and I think that that is the
thing that I think you see a lot what to
do I'm gonna get that is also what to do
book different guests but you know be
true to yourself I mean like big I think
it's like well I think this is I think
being true to yourself it's really easy
to say once you've found what yourself
if but be open to observing yourself hmm
you know I always say I always say it
says once and tweet which is like every
interviewer should has should have the
experience of being interviewed and by
that I mean they should go to therapy
but I do think the process of figuring
out who you are and what you value I
think is power mountain your paramount
that your ability to create work that
responds to yourself like I think and
like it I started the show because I was
interested in drove jokes and I wanted
to show people that jokes were hard to
do or whatever and then I also wanted to
show that not all comedians are the same
types a person
but as time has gone on the shows become
much more about my worldview and how
special I think comedy is and to sort of
be a surrogate to show people how to
treat comedy more specially to get more
out of it and that's sort of like what I
that became a and that took a lot of
work of trying to figure out like really
what I want to get out of it and I think
that's harder work than to like always
make sure you have a segment or whatever
which i think is useful but I think the
real answer is like really think about
what you want this thing to be yeah like
that's but that's only thing I know like
there's people who will give you exact
outfit advice because they're like trust
your gut right there's trust your gut
people and they'll say trust your gut
take her out if or your trust your gut
person or if your think about who you
are person and then do that if you're a
trust your gut don't do what I say do
whatever feels natural nice and when
when it comes to your gut what do you
think now that you have a context for
this show what we're trying to achieve
here where you're saying you want to
create comedy literacy for fans we want
to create common literacy for comedians
but we're getting bigger named guests
but what can I do to help take this show
to the level that I believe it should be
at which is at Just for Laughs festival
at these different like credible not
that I seek that for validation but just
to help more comedians and to also of
course build listeners so we can get
Judd Apatow to sponsor this one like
yours I mean I thank you I mean like
find a network you can be a part of
probably helps I mean you have your
guests are big enough that they're
probably the network then maybe it would
take you on but because cross-promotions
for the biggest way people find out
about parties and that's that's like it
I mean like I was all were always for me
getting attached to a major median
company so like
there was a value in having become a
just for laughs partly because I was me
being there is useful because like I
could moderate a bunch of panels I'm
like a experienced journalist mm-hmm
so like I have I had an external
validity that allowed my podcast to sort
of exist even before it had audience and
like I know whatever I've been grinding
it out and I think to your goal of like
making better comedians like it is
really about you know getting different
types of comedians that you know
Emmerich I think comedians do this
especially but it but all artists do it
which is you give advice based on your
experience and and the problem isn't
your advice your experience ends up
being incredibly specific to you like
people you know certain convene it's
like oh you should be clean because then
you can book more gigs or whatever and
then it's like well that only works if
you're sort of naturally good at a clean
write and it asked what we heard for you
and the point is like the more people
you book from a completely different
background that have completely
different experiences will give
different people different things they
could latch on to and different paths
they keep contrive because like so many
comedians will say the trick is doing it
as much as possible but that is not how
everyone did it that's not how Jenny
slate made it Jenny slate did not make
it because she did as much as possible
J slate was like kind of doing it once a
week but she was like living a life as
an artist and like figuring out who she
was because that's all she needed to do
like there's these American comedians
who are like the only way to do it is to
grind it out at clubs and do ten shows a
night was like that's not how they do in
Australia that's not how they do it in
the United Kingdom and like who's to say
that like and yes the best American
comedian there maybe better than the
than every other comedian but like I
don't I wouldn't say that like tears see
American club comedian is like better
than Daniel sloths or better than Ronny
Chang or better than Hannah Gatsby or
Ben
than any person comes out of like a
system where you're actually doing an
hour first and you build the whole show
thing that's your thing like and doesn't
mean that isn't your thing I think like
your ability you do have the ability
exposed to a little different things and
and not tell them comedy has to be this
one thing and that is the only way in
which more people are gonna be more
satisfied what they're doing is not
feeling the need to have to pay
themselves in one box because not
everyone's gonna be able to do
everything but doesn't mean what you're
doing is wrong
like don't accept certain value systems
just because the comedian you like most
does it that just might not be our thing
like there's nice comedians who favorite
types of comedians are harsh and they
just you know like Jim Gaffigan is a
non-political comedian who likes lefty
political comedian but he knows that
sort of not what he can do and that's
not like the true to his art form like
essentially you sort of have to like
give yourself more options and be like
oh maybe that's my type of thing and
like try things out and you have the
ability to sort of like expose people of
those things so you know the terms of
the services of comedians that's your
best thing you can do it's like try to
get people from different scene I mean
because it's it's possible the one thing
that a comedian needs to unlock
everything is one writing technique that
they haven't heard before and people
have I asked I asked Tom with every
guest how what is writing mean to them
is every comedian says they write jokes
right men like some people mean they
wrecked me they write forward down and
they write the other word and some
people like pen Oswell means he does the
dishes and he thinks about a thing for a
while or Ray Romano has an idea he talks
to his friend on the way to the club he
says he repeats their full conversation
except for his friends part and then
based on what they laugh then that and
they just that's what he does Maria
Bamford gets coffee with one person and
does her act for that person maybe
that's what you need to do person who's
listening so that said and that is like
what is like Oh in terms of a cure sir
so comedians like that's probably gonna
be bad cells between what's most
entertaining cuz even if you disagreed
like did you think this is an option is
out there there's so many ways up the
mountain in terms of popularity it's
like you know you just keep on doing and
you hope the people that are guest tweet
n you and then maybe you know try to get
trade ads with people trade ads with
people okay
yeah like go to another podcast that you
soup missus populist yours and be like
I'll do an ad for your podcast you don't
ad for mine Oh interesting
okay guys called ad swaps ad swaps
alright I will remember that cuz that a
feel like is the next step of scaling
this up to over 200 interviews with a
lot of big-name comedians it's like what
do we gotta do
so yeah that'll be helpful if
advertising could be a thing that's like
in terms of getting audience yeah
literally have L&P having a people who
listen to podcast want to be told on
podcast other podcasts it was too
because they're already listening to it
like like written articles I have not
seen too much but like if you get a
bunch of like appearing on other shows
is probably also really useful you know
mm-hmm it just like getting the word out
through the other shows gotcha perfect
alright well this has exceeded
expectations I can't thank you enough
for your time and this just comedy
powwow we just had its I hope people oh
now you like you now you sound like
Seinfeld saying he doesn't think jokes
or jokes are boring to other people you
know like famously funny people I know
like I contend that I could be
interesting but um they do not would
never sit I am as funny as funny
no that's and comedians have come on
here before it's like I wasn't really
that funny throughout it but the purpose
of this isn't to be funny
there could be organically funny moments
but that's not that's not the purpose of
this and people are saying I yeah go
ahead
I do tell yes
if you think you've being boring it's
okay I promise you people are trying to
get interesting well there you go see
it's the same Wayne said great interview
I'm Reese saying thanks guys great
interview Jodi
thanks guys great listen like yeah
people people are people level this and
I you're welcome
I thank you for spending so much time
with me because I feel like it is very
long but I you know like once I get
talking I feel like I you know oh no I
was I was in the moment with you
I was listening it's great to connect
with an interviewer of your level and
abilities so even just to get to even
interacting through DM I'm like this is
awesome so this was yes I know I've been
like I feel like a particularly regular
person but and then if you just know me
is like a thing that seems so produced
Frank if you we're editing me not set me
static more normal thanks I've been on
podcast where you're like oh this is
what they're like regularly like oh they
edit out all this please everyone seems
a little bit more human where it's like
if you just hear me finish like wow I
didn't you think of all that stuff on
the spot I was like why I don't I had
people who the soup I didn't write down
the questions ahead of time and I'm like
you must think I'm like the smartest man
on earth yeah yeah I I always I keep do
you keep all of your notes and research
do you have it documented somewhere I
mean it don't Google it's all in Google
Docs okay yeah I have a notebook of all
my show notes that kind of like I feel
like will be a book someday or something
we make we make posts of the transcripts
or whatever yeah yeah I mean I've done
it without with just like their brain
I'm like you to me that's impressive but
like you know do you want to be prepared
I mean my course no so yeah if anyone
thinks that it it's easy I'm like I mean
I put on yeah I feel like everyone's
like this guy put a lot of work yeah but
it's worth it yeah like you said with
the like with a fail you were talking
about but you have to enjoy the work in
order to like really appreciate those
failures as lessons so yeah this this is
now an official add swap
go listen to Goodwin see what I did
there see what I did there
but go listen to Goodwin it is it's the
it's the like the gold standard when it
comes to comedy podcast interviews if
you love this show you're gonna love
that one and most likely you already
listen to it they actually are now doing
weekly we're gonna start releasing
additional beyond dissecting like jokes
that are out now but dissecting
comedians that aren't even alive anymore
and really getting into that because
your affinity for Robin Harris's is like
a little interesting to me it's like
there's a lot you're about to do with
this show we've not any of those
episodes partly because it feels like
really morbid to do death related things
so we've been waiting oh that's like you
know I've talked to Sarah Keys let's do
campus that's about comedians they like
but yeah it feels like the vibe isn't
right like they feel like death is
already too much in the air to be like
let's talk about how Robin Harris died
before he got his big break but you're
looking to diversify the content and
you're really looking to start rolling
out more and thinking I guess beyond
just like the normal format interview
like I think there's something I think I
am capable of talking about comedy in a
way that is listenable and the audience
would probably appreciate it and/or
create a deeper relationship with me so
I think it's important to offer them
that to sort of like really build the
show around like my point of view
opposed to just saying like oh good once
the show where we do this one specific
thing because like I did that episode
with my coworker Catherine when we
talked about best specials of the year
and I'm like I think this is really I
think this was really interesting and so
I wanted more opportunities with that
because I do think it makes for a better
show like a more full a fuller show in
terms of pull show experience imposed to
just like oh you have to come to the
show for to listen to the guests you
already like it's like oh the shows less
guest dependent more
from my point of view dependent any
aspirations of doing video as well no
not not filming me I would be in my head
about it I would like just be wary but
worried about where my hairline was
inside we talked about doing film things
that are in the spirit of good one that
use the same vocabulary but not filming
me doing interviews perfect
alright well ladies and gentlemen of the
hot breath of first let's give a round
of applause for the one and only Jesse
David Fox thank you so much to everyone
that tuned in today that ask questions
go check out good one it's available
wherever you listen to podcasts is there
anything else you want to promote nope
do that per follow me on social media at
Fox and that's all right hop Brett the
first all those will be linked in the
show notes of this and we will see you
tomorrow with Ron Funches everyone so we
shall be back tomorrow at 2 p.m. again
so until then have a good day